I've been trying to think about the
story of Sodom and Gomorrah in
relationship to modern sexual confusion,
so this is what I see happening on the
social justice front,
let's say on the one hand since the 19
sixties and probably as a consequence of
the birth control pill,
but other factors as well.
There's been tremendous stress placed on
sexual liberation and so there's this
idea that I think is associated in large
part right now with the radical left of
total sexual freedom,
but at the same time there's increasing
emphasis from exactly the same sources
on restricting sexual interaction.
So you see this in the campuses,
for example,
where increasingly particularly
heterosexual contact is regulated by a
doctrine that says you have to get
spoken permission for every move in the
mating process.
And so you see,
and I know I'm not expressing myself
very well,
but there seems to be in our current
culture,
there seems to be massive sexual
confusion.
It's,
it's some weird combination of extreme
libertinism and extreme authoritarian
attitudes towards sexuality and and
obviously in the story of Sodom.
Part of what's happening happening and
is that sex impulsive?
Sexual gratification trumps everything.
It's something like that.
I mean I know there's more to what's
going on in Sodom than that,
but there's certainly that and so.
Well,
I'm trying to figure out what to say
about that tonight because there's a.
there's a lesson in there.
The lesson is something like,
don't let sexuality,
don't let impulsive sexuality get the
upper hand.
It's something like that or all hell
will break loose,
which I actually happen to agree with
because one of the things that we
haven't been able to talk about in our
culture I think is let's take the idea
of the phenomena of aids aids mutated to
take advantage of promiscuous sexuality
and that's just nothing.
You never hear that publicized.
You know,
people had associated aids with
homosexuality and there was a reason for
that because it's much more easily
transmitted as a consequence of
homosexual sex than heterosexual sex
because the anus is a much more delicate
physiological structure.
It's not as robust and it can be much
more easily damaged and and,
and with with disease resulting as a
consequence,
but it isn't only the manner of sexual
action.
That's the issue,
it's also the fact that promiscuity
provided the evolutionary platform for
the aids virus to mutate into a very
into the form that it finally took and
it was only through by the skin of our
teeth that we escaped a totalizing
plague.
You know,
had that emerged 100 years ago.
God only knows how many people would
have died.
It was.
AIDS was unbelievably so.
I know that's a mishmash of ideas and
I'm not exactly sure how to see my way
clear through it,
but there is a clear warning in that
story about,
about something,
about something to do with,
with,
with sexual inequity,
but in the Bible that sexuality has to
two Poles that define it and it's pretty
clear.
One,
what inside is reproduction and the
other side is we could,
let's say Rick Creation.
Okay,
so those are the two poles of sexuality
in a normal word.
So it's not just for reproduction and
it's not just for recreation.
It's both.
You're right.
That was the idea.
I mean,
it's a natural idea.
Now,
if you,
if there's a balance there that should
be had,
if you lose this balance and they become
just about reproduction,
that's a problem and they fed.
It becomes just about recreation.
That's another problem.
Yup.
Okay.
It's not that complicated really,
but it's so politically incorrect to
talk about these things even though
they're obvious.
Well that nobody dares you talk about
it.
The thing is is that the most difficult
things to talk about are the things that
are obvious because when they're obvious
you don't have to talk about them and so
then when people start to question the
obvious,
you don't know what to say,
so.
So for example,
we would.
I'm thinking about the slut walks and so
women go out and they dress very
provocatively and they go out and
manifest their right to be as
provocative as they possibly can be
without being interfered with.
And I have some sympathy for that
perspective because it seems to me
appropriate for women to be.
The final arbiter is in sexual contact,
but on the other hand,
it also,
it's that whole exercise is blind to the
fact that clothing,
for example,
has communicative intent
and that
people broadcast their invitation to
sexual congress in a million ways,
subtle and not so subtle,
and you can't just say,
I have the right to broadcast myself in
any manner possible and be completely,
um,
can,
can be completely immune from the
consequences.
There's something wrong with that.
And with regards to basic sexual
morality,
no,
I've read things about like slut shaming
is that the more radical feminist types,
for example,
claim that women shouldn't be held
responsible for their sexual behavior in
some sense.
It shouldn't be held against them.
How many men they've slept with,
et cetera.
But then I think,
well,
you'd never recommend to someone that
they laid down naked on the,
on the side of the street with their
legs spread and invite anybody who walks
by to partake of the opportunity.
Everyone would regard that as
inappropriate,
I think without question.
And so what that indicates is that some
degree of sexual propriety is both
normative,
unethical.
And then of course you can start asking
yourself about what that degree of
social sexual propriety should be.
And it does have something to do with
getting the balance between reproduction
and recreation.
Right?
Well,
the thing is,
even in the Bible,
there's the two aspects.
Some stories are about just this aspect
in.
There are the most strange stories in
the Bible.
For example,
the story of Tamar is one of those.
So,
uh,
I don't know if you're familiar with
that story,
but it's tough.
It's in the,
it's,
it's intercut with the story of Joseph
in Egypt and it's essentially a,
it says that Judah had children with
some woman and I think it's a stranger.
It doesn't necessarily say so,
but it,
it seems like that's what it is.
And then the sons die off.
And then there's this woman called Tamar
and she disguises herself as a
prostitute.
Great.
And she has a kid with Judah himself.
So all of the symbols heard that story.
Elements of his clothing.
Yeah.
Damage
as a,
as a bride.
Yeah.
Essentially
he wants to indicate later that he's the
one who slept with.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So that story is about the necessity,
the need for the recreative part of
sexuality.
It's all about that symbolism.
It's all about the seat.
It's all about incest,
it's all about death and it's the idea
is it's to raise the dead.
Okay.
It's not clear in the story,
but if you understand,
if you understand the imagery,
that's what it's about.
It's about regressing back to an error
that was made.
Okay.
And raising the dead.
So I don't want to get into it.
But it's just the idea that in the Bible
there's both to the hearse reproduction
and there's recreation and the
recreation is renewal.
There's the renewal.
Sexuality is about renewal too.
But that aspect of the symbolism is,
is pretty.
I don't want to say obscure because it's
actually right there if you can see it,
but it's strange.
I'll say it like that.
Strange.
Okay.
So now another element of this might be
the fact that in modern identity
politics,
sexual choice is a canonical identifier
and that also seems to me to be
something wrong about that.
Like one of the things I've seen
happening in Toronto,
I'm sure it's the same in Montreal,
is that,
and I'm going to do this awkwardly,
I'm going to put this awkwardly because
I haven't been able to sort through it
properly.
Um,
pride week,
Pride Day has turned into pride week and
that's turned into pride month and I
think that seems to me to be pushing
against some kind of limit because the
first question that I have is like I was
reading this book the other day by a
friend of mine from Ottawa who's a gay
conservative and he said he had a lot
harder time coming out as a conservative
then he had as coming out as gay and he
talked about the degree to which
homosexuals were persecuted in Canada
before say the 19 eighties.
And it's quite,
it makes quite a harsh reading,
let's say.
And so and so fair enough to the,
to the civil rights movement,
let's say it,
that,
that has brought homosexuality into the
norm or that into the mainstream.
Maybe that's one way of thinking about
it,
but that conversation still has a
tremendous amount of development.
That's necessary because I don't
understand exactly,
it isn't obvious to me what integration
into the mainstream precisely means
because a lot,
there's been a lot of talk so far about
respecting the rights of gay people,
but very little talk about what the
accompanying responsibilities might be.
Not Actually,
it seems to me to be a problem and I
mean I just had a letter from,
from Guy Gay guy who has been wrestling
with this because he's not sure how to
be gay and to be ethical at the same
time,
you know,
because he sees part of normative
behavior is taking wife and having
children and not and can see the value
in that,
but that's certainly not the direction
of his proclivity.
And so we wrote,
wrote to me asking me what he should do
and you know,
I don't have an answer for that.
I don't know what the answer to that is,
but I know that it might be something
that would be worth talking about and
it's part of this current confusion
about sexual identity and sexual
pleasure and,
and well even gender identity for that
matter.
So.
All right,
so your idea was,
well the balance between recreation and
reproduction had gone,
was completely absent inside of it was
all recreation.
It was all instant gratification.
Impulse.
Yeah.
And that's why it's put in contrast with
the Abraham bit because it's the same
angels,
but in that case he,
he says you'll have a son this time next
year,
so it's the reproduction part is there,
but when he gets to the bottom,
it's not there anymore.
It's only the recreation part.
Okay.
So yeah,
so they're,
they're,
they're meant to be contested.
Those two stores actually in the story
of Abraham,
it's pretty clear he,
I don't know if this will make sense
because when the angels come it,
it says,
um,
he washes their feet and then he feeds
them.
Okay.
That's actually the recreation and
reproduction part that not in terms of
sexuality,
but it's in terms of meaning the
renewal,
the washing of the feet is the
recreation part,
their renewal,
they're restarting and the feeding is
the reproduction part.
Not,
not in a sexual way,
but when you feed something food and he
eats it,
it integrates,
it integrates it correctly.
That's like our reproduction of your
identity,
your you're staying yourself,
you're reproducing yourself,
so when you eat food,
that's what you're doing.
Not like I said,
not in a sexual way,
but it has the exactly the same.
Meaning if you eat something that you
can integrate correctly,
you're reproducing your pattern.
It's like the correct version of
yourself.
The other side,
the washing is like,
is little flood
the fuck.
So many flood,
right?
It also is an acceptable.
It's a controlled one.
You're washing the dust off the roads,
dust off your feet.
It means that you're.
You're passing from one mode of being
into another because you're.
You're cleaning off the debris of the
past.
It's something like that and it's about
renewal next.
Okay,
so you have to see that when,
when,
when matthew was talking about,
yeah,
and you have recreation,
you have to understand that recreation
and rest are basically the same thing.
Then you basically have the same
meaning.
It's sleeping.
Resting recreation are all things that
bring you into renewal.
Okay,
bye.
And dying.
That's what dying is.
It's passing into another state letting
something else have a chance.
That's quit tying is it's then.